Today's changing world needs
principled leaders who are inentional
about developing their own personal
leadership competencies and values.
This is why we're so excited about this
new course which will be the foundation
for the lead personal
leadership certificate.
Brian, can you tell us a little
bit more about the course?
>> Of course.
So in this course, we're going to blend
research, practical exercises, and
a 360 tool, so the participants in the
course will be able to better craft their
own personal leadership journey.
So who is the course for, Sara?
>> So this course is terrific for
the new leader, as well as for
the seasoned executive.
New leaders will learn about their
own strengths and weaknesses and
use this information to both craft their
own personal leadership journey and
chart their course
through the certificate.
But because personal leadership is always
an evolving journey, it's important for
the more seasoned leader to examine
their leadership habits critically and
make course corrections as needed.
In other words, we've designed
this course to be useful for
both new and seasoned leaders.
Brian, tell us a little
more about how the course
is set up.
>> This course provides leadership lessons
from a number of experts who will
share their own unique knowledge
of a given topic.
The topics we have curated for the course
focus on building the core competencies of
personal leadership, which are self
awareness, perspective taking,
awareness of the context in which
interaction takes place, communication,
and decision making.
>> Participants
will leave this course with a much deeper
knowledge about themselves as leaders,
and this will allow them to begin to chart
their own personal leadership journey.